I was always doing crazy [__] and I was
getting away with a lot of crazy [__] so
it came a time I'm not stupid I knew
that something was going to happen yeah
eventually yeah my prayer was that it
didn't happen that would be so bad that
would take me out of the game so I
didn't get involved in that high level
[__] yeah but you never know what you're
doing and that's what happened with me
so when I was here in 84
the safest thing for me to do was to rub
drug dealers
why was that the safest because they
they can't go to nobody else they can't
hit but they got their people but in
those days it was a lot of yahoos
thinking they were gangsters when I came
back in when I was here in 82 with 83
people were selling Coke when I got here
in 84
it was an abundance of Coke
and it's like I left here and you guys
were nice college guys a bunch of guys
like me trying to be Scarface I left the
money in a code game that the goofies
came into the code game and you start
robbing it and it's glorified probably
because people who weren't prepared for
that type of Life yeah yeah yeah yeah
they had to sold the nickel bag on a
corner cocaine's high stakes yeah it's
high stakes you know and an ounce of two
and it just that became the norm for me
and my friends I had like two friends
would turn me on to it I'm like this
ain't a bad [__] idea
you know but at that time I was taking
everything that wasn't stapled
I always found the problem
oh it's a beauty yeah
you know that because you're a junkie
does that ever leave you what do you
mean no no no like even to this day do
you like see nice [__] and you're like
nobody would even notice and I could
walk right out of here with that [__]
lamp it's crazy the [__] that you know
this but now you can't do it right you
giggle but you think about it but [__]
you know I would walk into a mall I
remember one time in Boulder there was a
CD player like when CDs were brand new
yeah and I know the guy was on display I
mean by unplugged it put the quarter
around I even had the remote and I just
walked out of the mall with it
and nobody said booty and that's when
you go what
looking at I want to know what people
are looking at because they're not
paying attention my thievery came from
other people's mistakes and I saw a
little stupid in your game I had to rob
you yeah if you're gonna be this stupid
we gotta Rob here we have to we have to
teach you a lesson we have to teach you
a lesson if you're going to be this
[__] stupid yeah yeah there was a guy
in my neighbor that didn't want to bring
the coke into his house so he'd pied the
container under his car on a hill that
genius I would drive by and go huh there
goes my coke fix for the day I always
just go on his thing I got two
containers and go back and he would
always go somebody keeps stealing my
Coke
no you just take it yeah a little bit
bro to go because he'll move it yeah if
you take it off yeah
siphon it off a little